your number one move is
you identifying who you want to be not
not who tiffany wants to be not who
it's who do you want to be not not what
patrick wants to be not what bob you
want not what your older brother sister
mom that
who do you want to be if you and i can
figure out
who we want to be and it's as
transparent
and as clear as possible i don't have to
compare myself against your success
now here's a problem though say for
instance i
sit there and i say honestly i just want
to be a person that's just a regular
person and i'm glad if i make 80 grand a
year
100 grand a year i have a nice place i'm
married i'm happy my kids are with me i
have good relationships
i'm totally happy if you say that
if that's what you want to be if you say
that's what you want to be but if you
say i want something else
and you're not doing it then what
exactly but watch this one if you say
that's what you want to be and you're
content with that life
but behind closed doors your buddy lewis
house
is making millions he's doing great he's
all over the place people are talking
about it
if an ounce of envy or jealousy comes in
you either weren't being honest with
yourself because that's not exactly who
you want it to be
or you gotta ask the decision am i
living my life or his life that's the
toughest thing to do
right toughest thing to know now the
other side of it is that let's just say
you got a big upside you know in sports
a lot of times you know steven a smith
did an interview the other day and they
asked them about vince carter and it was
the toughest question what
that was asked they said so vince carter
he just announced 23 years of retirement
he's leaving the nba
stephen a what can you say about vince
carter's legacy
okay now i don't know if you guys know
vince carter's this guy dumped over the
seven footer in the olympics the guy
retired afterwards
with the elbow sick what he was doing in
toronto mcgrady it's just
beautiful when you watch this guy play
remember one time he dropped 50 in the
playoffs
you thought this guy's going to win the
championships and he came from tar heels
north carolina he's going to be the next
mike
but here's what stephen said about vince
carter very difficult
he said you know how stephen he does his
thing he's kind of like you know
and you know he typically is quick to
give the answer
one second goes by two seconds goes by
five second goes by
he still hasn't said a word then all of
a sudden he says
well i got to tell you this is a good
brother i love this man he's a great man
you know he goes into building them up
and then he says
but it is the most unfulfilled talent
we've ever seen in the history of the
nba really
he says this man should have been
competing with the kobes of the world
the lebrons of the world the jordans of
the world but we never saw it
i wish i would have seen the best of him
and you it's like a minute and 13
seconds it's so awkward
if vince carter watches that and it
doesn't bother him
more more power to you because you were
happy to be in the nba and you were cool
with that
but if you watch that and it bothers you
you know deep down and said he could
have done more
so you as the individual have to make a
decision either i'm going for all the i
want all the marbles
and i'm willing to go be embarrassed
lose public humiliation after another
one after until i get there
or i'm gonna live a simple life and i'm
okay with this but you have to be clear
about that that's step number one